Wir wollen eine Veränderung.
Es ist Zeit für eine Veränderung.
Nicht morgen, nicht übermorgen,
sondern jetzt.
(Sprechchor) Wir sind hier, wir sind
laut, weil man uns die Zukunft klaut.
Die Fakten sind klar,
die Lösungsvorschläge vorhanden,
aber umgesetzt wird es nicht.
Wir sagen: "Die Politik
muss es endlich umsetzen."
Viele haben kein Verständnis dafür,
dass ich mich
für Politik interessiere.
Aber das Thema ist so dringend -
wie kann man sich
nicht dafür interessieren?
(Sprechchor) Wir sind hier, wir sind
laut, weil man uns die Zukunft klaut.
Wir haben erst gerade angefangen,
einen Riesenwirbel zu verursachen.
Geschätzte Medienschaffende,
geschätzte Streikerinnen
und Streiker,
besten Dank
fürs zahlreiche Erscheinen.
Das sind
die Schülerinnen und Schüler,
die die Klimadiskussion
in der Schweiz vorantreiben.
An einer zweitägigen Konferenz
vor zwei Wochen
haben sie den internationalen
Streiktag vom 15. März geplant
und gemeinsam geklärt,
wie sie sich zur institutionellen
Politik stellen wollen.
Wir sind eine
unabhängige politische Bewegung,
geben keine Wahlempfehlungen,
unterstützen keine Parteien
oder Personen.
Gibt es einen Konsens
zu dieser Medienmitteilung?
Est-ce qu'il y a un consensus
sur cette proposition?
Das Ziel unserer Bewegung,
wahrgenommen zu werden,
ist schon mal erreicht.
Veränderungen
wurden aber noch keine eingeleitet.
Gerade international konnten wir
eine unglaubliche Bewegung aufbauen.
Wir stehen aber erst am Anfang.
Seit dem WEF
haben wir ordentlich Schub erhalten.
Wir blenden zurück:
Es ist Ende Januar.
Jonas, Janina und Jonathan
sind auf dem Weg nach Davos.
Die drei Gymischüler aus Wetzikon
wollen am WEF
für den Klimaschutz demonstrieren.
Jonas muss noch texten.
Am Anfang werde ich
ins Publikum rufen: What do we want?
Climate justice.
- Climate justice.
When do we want it?
- Now.
Die Klimakrise
hätte nie so ein Ausmass erreicht,
ohne brutale und harte Ausbeutung.
Wir schreiben gerade
die Rede fürs WEF.
Ich wurde für die Rede
gestern um 20 Uhr angefragt.
Wir waren uns nicht sicher,
ob Greta kommt,
deshalb haben wir ihr einen Slot
für eine Rede freigehalten.
Und da sie jetzt nicht kommt,
haben sie spontan mich angefragt.
Am Tag zuvor ist die 16-jährige
Greta Thunberg in Davos angekommen,
empfangen wurde sie wie ein Star.
Mit ihrer Rede
an der Klimakonferenz von Kattowitz
hat die junge Schwedin
viele Jugendliche aufgerüttelt
und eine nicht erwartete Dynamik
in die Klimadiskussion gebracht.
(Englisch)
Greta spricht aus, was viele denken
und die Jungen
schon lange beschäftigt.
Im Dezember haben sich etwa
100 Schüler/-innen in der Schweiz
zu einem WhatsApp-Chat
zusammengeschlossen,
um aktiv etwas
gegen die Klimaerwärmung zu tun.
Aus dem WhatsApp-Chat
ist mittlerweile eine
nationale Klimabewegung geworden.
Die Demo in Davos
hat die JUSO organisiert.
Jonas ist seit letztem Sommer
Mitglied und kennt fast alle hier.
(Sprechchor)
... weil man uns die Zukunft klaut.
Wir haben angefangen,
uns zu bewegen.
Wir werden nicht ruhen,
bis wir wieder eine Zukunft haben.
Gemeinsam können wir erreichen,
wofür wir kämpfen.
Alles lief sehr schnell und spontan.
Jetzt folgt die richtige Arbeit:
Wohin wollen wir? Usw.
Das müssen wir
nächste Woche herausfinden.
Überall in der Schweiz
haben sich Jugendliche organisiert.
An einem Sonntagnachmittag
findet eine Sitzung
der Basler Klimagruppe statt.
Die Flyer für die geplante nationale
Demo vom 2. Februar sind da.
Gib sie deiner Mutter!
Ich bin stolz auf das recycelte
und plastikfreie Papier.
Das war bei uns
eine grosse Diskussion.
Nele und ihre Freundin Pauline sind
im Komitee an vorderster Front dabei.
Politisch aktiv
waren die beiden bisher nicht.
Ich war zufälligerweise
schon ziemlich früh im Chat dabei.
Damals waren etwa 20 Leute
in diesem Chat.
Innerhalb weniger Stunden
waren es 250, der Chat war voll,
denn bei WhatsApp
gibt es eine Begrenzung.
Ich habe fast geweint, ich dachte:
"Endlich passiert mal was."
Ich wünschte mir schon immer,
dass etwas passiert.
Ich glaube,
viele Leute fühlten ähnlich wie ich.
Es wurde grösser und grösser,
und viele wollten an die Demo,
um etwas zu verändern.
Ich habe das
als Funken wahrgenommen.
Alle wollten etwas unternehmen,
aber niemand hat dazu aufgerufen.
Dann hat jemand dazu aufgerufen,
und so ist es losgegangen.
Alle waren motiviert,
hatten Freude und Energie.
Das war toll.
Pauline informiert, was auf
nationaler Ebene beschlossen wurde.
Wir waren am 30. Dezember
am nationalen Treffen in Bern,
also ich, Livia, Philipp -
und sonst wer noch?
Ja, sie war auch dabei.
Dort ging es um die Organisation,
wie wir uns als Bewegung
organisieren wollen.
Es fanden sehr viele
Grundsatzdiskussionen statt.
Das war ziemlich anstrengend.
Entschieden wurde in Bern auch,
was man als Nächstes plant.
Am 15. März werden Dutzende Länder
gleichzeitig mitmachen.
Das ist international sehr vernetzt.
Es gibt
eine nationale Arbeitsgruppe,
die sich darum kümmert.
Die sind
mit extrem vielen Ländern vernetzt.
Letzthin ist jemand von uns
nach Berlin gereist,
um eine Rede zu halten.
D.h., wir haben
auch Kontakt mit Deutschland.
Die Bewegung
macht Druck in alle Richtungen.
Nele mahnt aber auch, selbst
mit gutem Beispiel voranzugehen.
Man darf nicht nur Änderungen
in der Politik fordern.
Wir müssen bei uns beginnen.
Wenn wir nicht bei uns beginnen,
sind wir unglaubwürdig.
Und dann
wird man nicht ernst genommen.
Viele Jugendliche fühlen sich von den
Erwachsenen nicht ernst genommen.
Gerade wenn man Unterschriften
sammelt, hört man Sprüche wie:
"Du hast keine Ahnung.
Ich habe 30 Jahre mehr Erfahrung."
"Ich kann dir sagen,
wie die Welt funktioniert."
Jetzt haben sich ganz viele
Jugendliche zusammengeschlossen,
und plötzlich
wird man ernst genommen.
Alle tragen sich
in Arbeitsgruppen ein,
damit nicht zu viel Arbeit
auf ein paar wenigen lastet.
Bolligen im Kanton Bern.
Hier wohnt Nina mit ihren Eltern.
Kommst du mir helfen?
Fleisch findet man auf der Pizza
in diesem Haushalt selten.
Wir essen Fleisch, Nina aber nicht,
schon seit ihrer Kindheit.
Wir essen sehr wenig
bzw. immer weniger Fleisch.
Das hat natürlich
auch mit Nina zu tun.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
das entsteht einfach so,
weil es klar ist,
dass ich kein Fleisch esse.
Das wirkt sich
dann automatisch so aus.
Mit drei wurde sie Vegetarierin.
Mit 15 war sie
zum ersten Mal an einer Demo.
Und seit Dezember
ist sie im Organisationskomitee
der Berner Klimastreikenden.
Im letzten Herbst aber war sie
noch in Marokko in den Ferien.
Wir sind geflogen.
Das war anders nicht möglich,
auch von der Zeit her.
Die Bewegung hat mir
den letzten Anstoss gegeben,
dass ich konsequenter werde
und auf viel mehr Dinge
viel konsequenter achten möchte.
Ich habe mich auch entschieden,
Flugreisen möglichst zu vermeiden.
Ich würde es jetzt anders machen.
Marokko?
- Ja.
Und die restliche Familie?
Schwierig. Wir müssten wohl
ein anderes Reiseziel wählen.
(Nina) Ich würde nicht sagen,
ich sei politisiert worden.
Wir haben aber auch schon zu Hause
über vieles diskutiert.
Ein Grossteil meiner Kleider ist
von Flohmärkten oder Brockenhäusern.
Das ist ein guter Weg,
denn man muss nicht viel umstellen,
nicht explizit auf etwas verzichten.
D.h. nicht,
dass ich nie was Neues kaufe.
Ich war auch schon im H&M.
Klar, ich bin nicht perfekt,
aber es ist wichtig,
dass man sich hinterfragt.
Ich bin nicht der Typ,
der wie vor 200 Jahren leben möchte.
Ich glaube,
Verzicht ist nicht der richtige Weg,
denn ich denke nicht, dass das
von der Mehrheit getragen wird.
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
Es braucht viel Verzicht
und auch Selbstreflexion.
Aber das alleine reicht nicht.
Es braucht auch politische Lösungen.
Nele und Pauline bereiten sich
auf die schweizweite Klimademo
vom Samstag vor.
Die Kartonplakate
aus Recyclingmaterial
sind das typische Erkennungszeichen
des Klimastreiks.
Was steht drauf?
Eine Schweigeminute für Politiker,
die nichts unternehmen.
Das sterbende Klima.
Aber wir glauben,
dass es wiederaufersteht.
Es ist ein sehr starkes Zeichen,
wenn alle
eine Schweigeminute abhalten.
Das gibt ein Gefühl
von Verbundenheit.
Letztes Mal war es etwas unklar,
wann sie beginnt und endet.
Jetzt können wir das
mit dem Schild klar signalisieren.
Das ist das Einzige,
was wir unternehmen können,
damit die Leute uns zuhören.
Tatsächlich bringen sie so
immer mehr Leute auf die Strasse,
auch wenn nicht alle
die gleiche Weltanschauung haben.
Wir haben Hardcore-Kommunisten,
Hardcore-Nicht-Kommunisten,
andere sind bürgerlich-rechts.
Wir sind eben unparteiisch.
Ich glaube,
der Klimawandel verbindet.
Aber trotzdem:
Wenn man zusammensitzt
und darüber diskutiert, was ganz
grundsätzlich unser Ziel ist ...
Klar ist: Wir wollen
den Klimawandel bekämpfen.
Aber wie soll das geschehen?
- Es gibt halt viele Wege.
Im unserem
derzeitigen Wirtschaftssystem
können wir den Klimawandel
wohl nicht bekämpfen.
Es geht immer nur um Wachstum,
um Wachstum auf Kosten von allen.
In unserem Wirtschaftssystem
ist das einfach so.
Nina ist auf dem Weg
zu einer Sitzung mit dem Rektor.
Sie geht ins Gymnasium Hofwil
in Münchenbuchsee.
Zu sechst dürfen sie dem Rektor
ihre Vorschläge präsentieren.
Ihr Katalog ist lang.
Es ist ein Gespräch.
Wir brauchen keinen genauen Ablauf.
Wichtig ist auch,
dass wir den Klimanotstand
als Überbegriff für unsere
Verbesserungsvorschläge nehmen.
U.a. fordern sie, das Schulhaus
nur noch auf maximal 21 °C zu heizen
und eine Podiumsdiskussion zum
Klimawandel veranstalten zu dürfen.
Also, die Delegation.
Ich kenne nicht alle Namen. - Nina.
Also, nehmt doch Platz.
Auch den Fleischkonsum
in der Mensa zu reduzieren,
ist ihnen ein grosses Anliegen.
Man kann jetzt schon wählen,
ob man vegetarisch essen möchte.
Das finde ich super, das ist
aber auch eine Voraussetzung.
Es geht einen Schritt weiter,
dass ein Statement abgegeben wird:
"Hofwil möchte in eine ökologischere
und nachhaltigere Richtung."
"Deshalb gibt es nur noch
zweimal pro Woche Fleisch."
(Nico) Damit nicht mehr das
Fleischmenü das normale Menü ist,
sondern das Vegimenü
das normale Menü ist.
Man könnte dann ein- bis zweimal
pro Woche einen Fleischtag machen.
Die Leute könnten auch
sensibilisiert werden,
wenn man z.B.
das Fleischmenü verteuert
und das Vegimenü
um 1 Fr. verbilligt.
Das würde alleine psychologisch
schon etwas auslösen,
denn man überlegt sich,
wieso das Fleischmenü teurer
als das vegetarische ist.
Ich könnte mir sehr gut vorstellen,
in eine solche Richtung zu gehen.
Da hätten wir auch
eine gewisse Handhabung.
In der Hoffnung,
dass es auch genutzt wird.
Rund ein Drittel
der Schüler/-innen im Hofwil
unterstützen die Klimastreikbewegung.
Die überzeugten Fleischesser
wollen sich nicht gross äussern.
Ich esse nicht sehr viel Fleisch,
nur ab und zu einmal.
Sie unterstützt die Forderung,
dass es nur noch zweimal Fleisch
pro Woche geben soll.
Das finde ich eigentlich gut.
Es ist für mich
in diesem Sinn kein Verzicht.
Ein guter Plan. Ich würde mich
sehr gerne vegetarisch ernähren,
schaffe es aber nicht,
da ich Fleisch sehr mag.
Es gibt noch den Punkt: Umgang
mit diesen Aktionen, diesen Streiks.
Wir unterstützen es,
dass ihr aktiv seid, euch engagiert,
als Schule sind wir aber
verpflichtet, Unterricht abzuhalten.
Wenn ihr in dieser Zeit
etwas machen wollt,
könnt ihr das
an euren freien Halbtagen tun.
Ihr könnt sie
für diese Zwecke einsetzen.
Die Vorstellung,
dafür Halbtage einzusetzen,
ist etwas utopisch
bzw. eher unrealistisch,
denn wir wollen
das regelmässig machen.
Wir haben nur
eine beschränkte Anzahl Halbtage.
Der Streik
richtet sich nicht gegen die Schule,
aber es ist symbolisch doch
ein Zeichen gegen ein System,
das erzeugt mehr Reibung.
Eine Lösung ist noch nicht in Sicht.
Die Delegation ist mit vielen
Anliegen auf offene Ohren gestossen,
aber es geht ihnen zu wenig schnell.
Sie finden es sehr gut,
was wir machen.
Die Podiumsdiskussionen
fanden sie z.B. ein gute Idee.
Ich würde jetzt gerne
die Umsetzung angehen,
aber es ist noch sehr viel offen,
vieles steht noch im Raum.
Nele hat Pauline
zum Abendessen eingeladen.
Beide essen kein Fleisch.
Zu Hause haben sie immer wieder
Diskussionen
über den Klimaschutz angestossen.
Irgendwann erreicht man einen Punkt,
an man realisiert,
wie scheisse es eigentlich ist,
was man für seine Umwelt, für sich
selbst und seine Zukunft tut.
Ich kann keinem eine Schuld geben,
der nicht darüber nachdenkt.
Ich kann niemanden
als schlechten Menschen bezeichnen,
weil er noch nie
sein Tun hinterfragt hat.
Das finde ich schon sehr cool.
Auch für mich selber.
Dass ich dank ihnen merke,
dass dieses Thema
die Menschheit wirklich berührt.
Es gibt sehr, sehr viele,
die bereit sind, aufzustehen.
Ich hoffe einfach,
dass sie gehört werden.
Im letzten Frühling
flogen wir nach Sizilien.
Das würden wir uns
jetzt wohl nochmals überlegen.
Ich finde schon,
das beeinflusst uns.
Das gibt uns als Familie etwas, mit
dem man sich auseinandersetzen kann.
Ich finde es total gut,
sie gibt viele Inputs.
Gerade aus deiner Klasse höre ich
von philosophischen Diskussionen,
die wir in diesem Alter
nie geführt haben,
z.B. über Fleischkonsum -
die sprechen in der Pause
über Fleischkonsum.
Neles Eltern
haben kein Problem damit,
dass die Jugendlichen
für ihre Anliegen streiken.
Wenn man streikt, dann streikt man.
Streik ist nie etwas Liebliches.
Wenn man streikt,
muss man mit Sanktionen rechnen.
Streik ist ein Kampfmittel.
Wenn es Sanktionen gibt,
dann nimmt man diese in Kauf.
An praktisch allen Schulen
wird diskutiert,
wie man die Sanktionen für
die Schülerstreiks handhaben soll.
Das bespricht heute
auch die Klimagruppe.
Wie immer
wird mit Handzeichen kommuniziert,
damit die basisdemokratische Sitzung
gesittet und nicht zu laut verläuft.
Zustimmung, Ablehnung,
vorwärtsmachen - was haben wir noch?
Technisch.
- Technische Dinge.
Ich fühle mich unwohl.
- Genau.
Wenn man etwas sagen möchte -
die erste Person macht so,
die zweite so, die dritte so.
Bezüglich Strafen: Die Schulleitung
ist sehr offen für unsere Anliegen.
Sie möchte mit uns zusammenarbeiten,
damit etwas Konstruktives entsteht.
Eine einfache Absenz reiche nicht,
es müsse etwas Konkretes sein,
dass man diese Stunden in
irgendeiner Form kompensieren kann.
Mein kleiner Bruder
ist auf mich zugekommen und meinte,
er wisse viel zu wenig
über den Klimawandel.
Er besucht noch die Primarschule.
Ich texte ihn dauernd zu, trotzdem
meint er, er wisse noch zu wenig.
Mir kam dann eine Idee,
was wir dagegen unternehmen könnten.
Wir könnten
2-3 Std. Unterricht vorbereiten
für Primar- und Sekundarschulen
zum Thema Klimawandel.
Damit sie es verstehen -
auf diesem Niveau.
Das gilt jetzt nur für jene,
die in der Organisation sind.
Aber was machen diejenigen,
die spontan kommen?
Nein, das würde
für alle Teilnehmer gelten.
Ich finde es wichtig,
dass wir es kompensieren müssen.
Die Leute, die deshalb nicht kommen,
wollten sowieso nur schwänzen.
Jonas hat den Job gefasst,
die Vorschläge
dem Rektor zu unterbreiten.
Grüezi.
- Grüezi wohl.
Wir hatten soeben
unsere Klimastreiksitzung.
Zur "Strafe" würden die Streikenden
an einem freien Nachmittag
in Primar- und Sekundarschulen gehen
und 2-3 Std. lang eine Einführung
ins Thema Klimawandel geben.
So ganz basic:
Was ist der Klimawandel?
Das klingt spannend.
Es hat eine schulische Komponente
und ist auch sinnvoll.
Es ist ein Gewinn für beide Seiten.
- Ja.
Die Leute, die sich nicht trauen,
vor eine Klasse zu stehen,
würden dann
Community service machen.
Malena würde dazu
eine Liste mit Orten erstellen,
wo man solche Arbeiten
verrichten könnte:
z.B. einen Park reinigen,
solche Dinge.
Wir würden also beides machen.
- Jawohl.
Vielen Dank für die Vorschläge.
- Cool.
Ich nehme sie mit in die
Schulleitung. Ich finde das toll.
Jonathan arbeitet an dieser,
Malena an der anderen Sache.
Wir haben Leute,
die das ausarbeiten.
Sehr schön. Merci viel mal.
Gemeinsam
hat man sich später darauf geeinigt,
dass die Absenzen mit Arbeiten in der
Gemeinde kompensiert werden können,
die dem Klima zugute kommen.
Auch die Berner
malen Transparente für die Demo.
In ihrer Freizeit selbstverständlich.
Lautet das Sprichwort nicht
"fünf nach zwölf"?
Dann ist es zu spät.
- Nein, der letzte Moment.
Fünf vor zwölf bedeutet,
man hat noch genug Zeit.
Nein, dann ist die Zeit abgelaufen.
Die Bewegung fordert:
keine Kohle-, keine Gas-
und Ölverbrennung mehr bis 2030.
Im Nationalrat kam letzten Winter
nicht mal eine Halbierung durch.
Das Wichtigste ist,
dass jetzt gehandelt wird.
Wir wollen das Beste herausholen.
Deshalb müssen die Ziele
hoch gesteckt sein.
Falls ihre Ziele
nicht erreicht werden,
fordern sie einen Systemwandel.
Was genau verstehen sie darunter?
Es ist nicht die Aufgabe
von Gymnasiasten, Schülern
oder Lehrlingen,
einen Systemwandel vorzuschlagen,
auszuarbeiten.
Das ist klar Aufgabe der Politik.
Die Schülerinnen und Schüler
positionieren sich klar.
Sie wollen aus Prinzip
nicht mit Parteien zusammenarbeiten.
Wir wollen uns als Organisation
nicht als links
oder rechts einordnen.
Wir wollen uns
politisch nicht positionieren,
denn die Frage betrifft alle.
Das Problem der Politik ist,
dass sie Kompromisse eingeht.
Aber beim Kampf gegen den Klima-
wandel gibt es keine Kompromisse.
Aber sie sind nicht nur optimistisch.
Ich bin sehr pessimistisch.
Ich sehe es sehr realistisch.
Auch wenn ich denke,
dass die Chancen niedrig sind,
wir es wohl kaum schaffen,
trage ich das nicht gegen aussen,
weil ich nicht möchte, dass andere
dadurch negativ beeinflusst werden.
Der Optimismus der anderen
kann ich aufnehmen und hilft mir,
daran zu glauben.
Es geht nicht um uns als Individuen.
Es nützt nichts, zu Hause zu weinen,
weil die Welt untergeht,
wir müssen etwas
dagegen unternehmen.
Nele und Pauline wenden etwa 3 Std.
täglich für die Klimabewegung auf.
Sie sind u.a.
für die Medienarbeit zuständig
und setzen sich dadurch
auch ziemlich aus.
Wenn man einmal in einem
Zeitungsartikel erwähnt worden ist,
dann kriegt man Fragen über Fragen,
Kritik und Lob.
Mit Kritik umzugehen,
ist am Anfang schwierig.
Viele haben kein Verständnis dafür,
dass ich mich in diesem Alter
für Politik interessiere.
Aber das Thema ist so dringend -
wie kann man sich
nicht dafür interessieren?
Online wird geschrieben
oder mir auch ins Gesicht gesagt,
dass es falsch ist, was ich mache,
Schüler sowieso
nichts verändern können
und wir selber nichts
fürs Klima machen.
Es wird sofort davon ausgegangen,
dass wir mit dem Auto
zur Schule gefahren werden,
Plastikprodukte benutzen und
klimaschädigende Produkte kaufen.
Irgendwie möchte man uns ...
Man will uns an den Pranger stellen.
... auch das Rückgrat brechen.
Man findet,
dies und jenes sei scheisse,
wir sollten
unser ganzes Leben umkrempeln,
Jugendliche laufen nur
in Markenkleidern herum.
Ein bisschen gelassener nehmen sie
es bereits, und sie wehren sich,
speziell wenn man ihnen vorwirft,
sie seien nicht glaubwürdig,
nur weil sie ein Handy hätten.
Erstens: Wir wissen alle, dass heute
ohne Handy nichts mehr läuft.
Zweitens kaufen wir
alle keine neuen Handys,
nur secondhand, übernehmen es von
Leuten, die es nicht mehr brauchen.
Oft geht man davon aus,
wir hätten alle das neuste Handy.
Es geht auch immer
auf die persönliche Ebene.
Aber auch wenn wir nicht perfekt
sind, können wir Kritik üben.
Im Schulhaus Hofwil ruft die
Klimagruppe zur Demo am Samstag auf.
Leute, morgen ist Klimademo,
um 13 Uhr auf dem Waisenhausplatz.
Ihr dürft laut und böse sein,
weil das Klima wütend macht,
und für eure Zukunft kämpfen.
* Treibende Musik *
Nicht alle sind Feuer und Flamme.
Die Aktivistinnen und Aktivisten
sind in der Minderheit.
Zusammen haben wir Kraft.
Nehmt alle mit, die ihr kennt:
Eltern, Grosseltern, Cousins,
die ganze Verwandtschaft,
Haustiere - egal, was.
Kommt und seid laut!
Ihr könnt Pfannen
und Trillerpfeifen mitnehmen
und Krach machen
und Parolen schreien.
Vielleicht lassen sich in der Mensa
noch ein paar Leute überzeugen.
Ja, es ist nicht
mit jeder Konsequenz.
Wenn ich sehe, wie ihr dort dann
mit Plastikbechern rumlauft ...
Also, an der Demo
hat niemand einen Plastikbecher.
Das Problem ist halt auch,
dass 71 % der Emissionen
von den 100 grössten Unternehmen
ausgestossen werden, nicht von uns.
Wir wollen Druck
auf die Politik machen,
damit sie
diese Unternehmen einschränken.
Es liegt kein Druck
auf dem Individuum.
Jeder soll tun,
was er oder sie kann.
Darum ist es kein Argument,
zu sagen:
"Die Jugendlichen tun selbst
nichts." Es liegt nicht an uns.
Das habe ich so auch nicht gesagt.
Wir kennen einander
ja gut und lange.
Wir kennen die Werte, die wir haben.
Das ist die Rückmeldung,
die wir von Älteren bekommen.
Ich fahre ein ökologisches Auto
und nehme euch oft mit.
Das Auto wird gefüllt.
- Nice.
* Treibende Musik *
Der Tag der nationalen Demo.
In Wetzikon macht sich Jonas
mit Elaine auf den Weg.
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Das ist meine Familie.
- Ah, hallo.
Hallo, ich bin Marc.
- Elaine, hallo.
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Ich bin Rahel. Hallo, Elaine.
* Basslastige Musik *
Es ist schon ... Bis jetzt
waren es v.a. Schüler/-innen
und Student/-innen
und Lernende und so.
Ich denke, heute wird sich zeigen,
wie gross die Resonanz
in der Bevölkerung ist.
Das mediale Interesse an den Schülern
ist gross.
V.a. Jonas
wurde von den Medien entdeckt.
Er lebt im Moment
praktisch nur für die Bewegung.
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Hey, hallo.
Hast du es rausgebracht?
- Ja. Es war spät.
Zeitungen, und Onlinemedien ...
Man verfolgt das ein wenig
und schaut auch darauf, dass er
nicht zu sehr unter die Räder gerät.
Er ist jetzt
unter seinem Namen bekannt.
Ja, da gibt es schon auch den einen
oder anderen negativen Kommentar.
Da finde ich, dass man einfach
ein wenig schauen muss,
dass er nicht zu sehr
die Aufmerksamkeit hat.
Er ist auch noch sehr jung.
Wir machen uns keine Sorgen,
aber wir besprechen mit ihm,
dass es Menschen gibt,
die durch solche Aktivitäten
in gewisse Burnout-Symptome
fallen können.
Das haben wir auf dem Radar,
und wir besprechen es auch mit ihm.
Wir hoffen damit, dass so etwas
gar nicht erst passiert.
Es sind schon megaviele da,
das ist cool.
Wir demonstrieren
in einem friedlichen Sinn.
Wir kooperieren mit der Polizei.
Diese Demo ist bewilligt.
Deswegen wollen wir keine Gewalt
und wir wollen keine Randalierer.
Darum lasst uns friedlich kämpfen!
* Jubel, Applaus *
Das Lätzchen.
Pauline ist noch beim Brunch.
Ihre Schwester
hat Nichte Frieda mitgebracht,
und Patentante Cordula
ist aus Berlin angereist.
Mutter Anne findet es gut,
dass ihre Tochter an die Demo geht
und sich engagiert.
Sicher nehmen sie einem etwas ab.
Ich glaube ...
Ich werfe mir vor,
dass mein politisches Engagement ...
... gegen null tendiert.
Das muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen.
Das ist nicht ... Natürlich
kann ich es mir schönreden:
"Ich beschäftige mich,
ich lese Zeitung."
Aber ich mache nichts.
Paulines Mutter
war früher in der Anti-AKW-Bewegung.
Willst du noch Gipfeli?
Du hast hier noch.
Sie sieht ein paar Unterschiede
zur Klimabewegung heute.
Von den Strukturen her
spüre ich hier einen Versuch,
dass eine grosse
Gleichberechtigung herrscht.
Im Kleinen gibt's natürlich
immer noch Machtkämpfe.
Die waren zu unserer Zeit,
glaube ich, offensichtlich.
Es war oft v.a. auch
eine Mann-Frau-Geschichte -
v.a. die Männer, die sich sehr
in den Vordergrund gestellt haben,
und wir Frauen, die das zuliessen.
Heute haben wir
Redner und Rednerinnen.
Zu Anfang hatten wir
eine Liste mit nur Männern.
Ist die einfach so entstanden?
- Die ist einfach so entstanden.
Die Männer haben sich gemeldet.
- Und jemand hat sie gegengelesen.
Wir sagten,
alle könnten ihre einschicken,
und jemand hat sie gegengelesen.
Diejenigen, die gute Reden hatten,
waren alles Männer.
Aber keine Frau
hat etwas eingeschickt.
Ja. Auf jeden Fall fanden Pauline
und ich, das sei scheisse.
Wir fanden,
es sollten auch Frauen reden.
Und dann hiess es: "Ja,
aber wenn die sich nicht melden?"
Und dann so: "Vielleicht hat man es
nicht richtig kommuniziert."
Viele Jungs, die dort reden,
sind Leute, die wir kennen,
die das von uns gehört haben.
Als wir es noch einmal sagten,
kamen dann schon auch Mädchen.
Wir haben jetzt Mädchen
auf der Liste.
Auch Pauline wird eine Rede halten.
(Sprechgesang) Rauf mit
dem Klimaziel! Runter mit dem CO2!
Rauf mit dem Klimaziel!
Runter mit dem CO2!
In zwölf verschiedenen
Schweizer Städten
gehen Menschen auf die Strasse.
Insgesamt sind es rund 60'000.
* Pfiffe, Applaus *
Hopp, hopp, hopp! Klimawandel stopp!
Unser Klima!
Das zeigt einfach:
Wir müssen weitermachen.
Wir müssen kämpfen,
bis wir das schaffen.
Eine solche Jugendbewegung
hat es seit den 80er-Jahren
nicht mehr gegeben.
Wenn wir alle daran glauben,
dass es weitergeht,
und einfach immer weitermachen,
egal, wie viele kommen,
geht's auch weiter.
Und jetzt gehe ich weiter.
(Alle) Wir sind hier, wir sind laut,
weil man uns die Zukunft klaut.
Nur 100 globale Konzerne
sind für 70 % aller CO2-Emissionen
verantwortlich:
Gazprom ...
* Buhrufe *
Gazprom, ExxonMobil, Chevron, BP,
Shell, Glencore und noch 94 weitere.
Da macht es wohl wenig Sinn,
zu behaupten,
wir könnten mit unserem Konsum-
verhalten die Klimakrise überwinden.
Jawohl, und jetzt folgt Musik
ganz nach dem Motto:
If I can not dance to it,
it is not my revolution.
* Unverständlicher Song *
Willkommen auf dem Bürkliplatz.
Wunderbar.
Danke vielmals, danke vielmals.
Ich habe kurz
fast kein Blut mehr im Kopf.
Hast du gegessen?
- Ja, ein Brot.
Nimm doch noch ein wenig Suppe!
Für Jonas, Fanny und Andri geht's
nach der Demo ohne Pause weiter.
Wir müssen hier rein, nicht?
- Ja.
* Orientalisch wirkende Musik *
Ihr hättet Jacqueline Badran
hören müssen.
(Jonas) Sie war da?
- Sie kam zu uns und sagte:
"Ich bin euch so dankbar,
dass ihr das tut."
"Ich hätte nicht gedacht,
dass ich das noch erlebe."
Sie hat fast geweint.
Es gibt vielen Zuversicht,
wenn man sagen kann: "Wir haben
viele auf die Strasse gebracht."
"Jetzt können wir weitermachen."
Wir müssen schauen, dass wir
keinen Burnout-Aktivismus machen.
(Lachend) Ist gut, Fanny.
Das machen wir ja nicht.
Wir schreiben irgendwelche
Medienmitteilungen im Tram -
das ist kein Burnout-Aktivismus.
Sie haben einen Interviewtermin
bei Radio 1.
* Treibende, basslastige Musik *
Wir nehmen diese Sendung direkt
nach der Demo am Samstagabend auf.
Bei mir im Studio
sind drei der Organisatoren.
Wer seid ihr?
- Ich bin Fanny, 17, Kantischülerin.
Und ... Ja, ich habe mal
regelmässig Musik gemacht,
aber jetzt
ist der Klimastreik gekommen.
Ich bin 17 und gehe auch
an die Kanti Zürich Oberland.
Ich hatte auch mal Hobbys.
- Du hattest mal Hobbys?
Ja, das kommt vor.
Aber seit zwei Monaten
bin ich jetzt auch dran,
diese Klimastreiks zu organisieren
und irgendwie die Welt zu retten.
Hattest du während der Demo mal
Angst, es könnte schiefgehen, Fanny?
Nein, eigentlich gar nicht.
Ich habe die allererste Rede
auf dem Denkmal
auf dem Helvetiaplatz gehalten
und mich umgeschaut.
Die Polizei hat uns gesagt:
"Achtet darauf,
dass ihr keine Trams blockiert!"
Es war einfach alles
voller Menschen.
Und dann?
- Es war einfach hammergeil.
Hattet ihr einen Kontrolldienst?
Wir hatten etwa sechs Personen
für 15'000 Menschen.
Das ist super.
- Ja, genau.
Man kann vielleicht sehen, dass wir
uns ein wenig unterschätzt haben.
Wenn man Forderungen stellt,
von denen man weiss,
dass sie nicht
umgesetzt werden können ...
Diese Zahl, 2030,
ist nicht einfach so gedacht:
"Das ist eine schöne Zahl", sondern
wir haben uns alle sehr eingehend
mit dem letzten Spezialbericht des
Weltklimarates auseinandergesetzt.
Es hat sich gezeigt,
dass die Emissionen bis 2050
auf netto null sein müssen.
Bis 2050.
- Auf der ganzen Welt, global.
Die Schweiz ist ein Industrieland,
d.h., wir müssen früher runter.
Wir sind ganz klar
wissenschaftlich vorgegangen
und stehen auch im Dialog
mit Klimawissenschaftlern.
Wie hoch schätzt ihr die Chance ein,
dass das passiert?
Wie gross schätzt du die Chance ein,
dass wir überleben?
Eine Gegenfrage ist immer gut,
wenn man keine gute Antwort hat.
Aber wie gross hätten Sie vor
einem Monat die Chance eingeschätzt,
dass heute 60'000 Menschen für den
Klimaschutz auf die Strasse gehen?
Es ist ein schöner Gedanke,
aber völlig realitätsfremd.
Da frage ich euch jetzt:
Ist das mit den
realitätsfremden Gedanken klug
oder müsstet ihr nicht eher
realistischere Szenarien aufzeigen?
Habt ihr das Gefühl, das sei
das Privileg von euch Jugendlichen?
"Wir müssen uns nicht
um die Realisierung kümmern."
Erstens: Wir müssen uns in dem Sinne
nicht um die Realisierung kümmern,
denn dafür haben wir Politiker
in unseren Parlamenten,
die Ahnung haben oder haben sollten.
Und Fakt ist: Wir haben diese Krise.
Wir müssen jetzt etwas tun.
Der Schulalltag geht weiter.
Etwa 50 Schülerinnen und Schüler
gehören wie Nele und Pauline
am Basler Leonhard-Gymnasium
zum harten Kern.
Die Demo vom Samstag hat
den Jugendlichen Auftrieb gegeben.
Ich glaube,
es ist keine Minderheit mehr.
Inzwischen
kann man das nicht mehr sagen.
Das sind jetzt die Gesprächsthemen.
Das ist, was uns jetzt bewegt,
und uns wird auch bewusst,
dass das jetzt
die Aufgabe unserer Generation ist.
Es steckt jetzt einfach
mehr in den Hinterköpfen
und man denkt mehr darüber nach, was
man in der Mittagspause konsumiert.
Gehen wir mit dem Flugzeug
auf die Maturareise?
Das ist jetzt
ein viel grösseres Thema.
Und die Schulleitung
hat bereits gehandelt.
Am Leonhard-Gymnasium wird in Zukunft
auf Flugreisen verzichtet.
Wir haben vorgestern
darüber abgestimmt.
Damit ist es für uns erledigt.
Wir unterstützen einerseits
die Schülerschaft,
und wir als Schule
haben entschieden ...
Es ist kein Verbot,
das wir aussprechen,
sondern wir als Schule
haben entschieden,
dass wir nicht mehr fliegen.
Aber d.h., die jungen
Klimaaktivistinnen und -aktivisten
haben an der Schule etwas erreicht.
- Ja, das haben sie.
Es ist ein persönlicher Beitrag,
den jeder leisten muss.
Wir sind in diesen Gesprächen -
gerade heute früh habe ich
bei einer Klasse reinhören dürfen.
Es gibt solche, die jetzt
einen Beitrag leisten müssen.
Es ist immer schwierig,
auf etwas verzichten zu müssen,
aber man kann nicht
den Fünfer und das Weggli haben.
Ich finde es super, denn man kann
auch mit dem Zug sehr gut wegfahren.
Und ich habe mal gehört -
ich weiss nicht, ob es stimmt -
dass man dann dafür
einen Tag mehr kriegt,
weil die Reise länger dauert.
Wir fahren z.B. über Nacht
nach Budapest.
Das geht gut. Ich finde es super.
Und Zug fahren macht ja auch Spass.
* Stimmengewirr *
Nele bringt ihr Essen
von zu Hause mit,
aber an einen gemütlichen Lunch
ist nicht zu denken.
Weil sie
für die Medienarbeit zuständig ist,
muss sie
die vielen verschiedenen Klimachats
regelmässig bewirtschaften.
Mega-asi, jetzt kann ich einfach
nicht mit euch reden.
Das Schulhaus hat einen eigenen Chat
für Klimaanliegen.
Hier werden Medienberichte, Filme
und politische Inhalte geteilt
und Fragen diskutiert.
250 Leute sind dabei.
Am letzten Mittwoch
mussten wir um 11 Uhr
noch notfallmässig
eine Medienmitteilung rausgeben.
Ich sah das in der 10-Uhr-Pause
und musste während des Unterrichts
immer unter dem Tisch mitlesen,
weil das megawichtig war.
D.h., ich habe das Gefühl, dass
dafür die meiste Zeit draufgeht.
Andere Schüler sind für
den Kontakt zur Politik zuständig.
Sie haben erreicht,
dass der Grosse Rat in Basel
über eine Resolution von ihnen
diskutiert.
Wir fordern darin, dass die Basler
Regierung den Klimanotstand ausruft,
sich dafür verantwortlich zeichnet,
die Bevölkerung, also nicht nur
Schülerinnen und Schüler,
sondern wirklich alle,
über den Klimawandel zu informieren,
und künftig die Priorität
auf klimaschützende
statt schädliche Projekte setzt.
Nach der Cellostunde
muss Pauline noch lernen.
Und auch Nele
sollte Biologie büffeln.
Hast du dein Deutschzeug dabei?
- Nein.
Schade.
Wir haben irgendwelche Hausaufgaben.
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
Wir folgen den Lernzielen:
Zellzyklus, DNA-Replikation,
Meselson-Stahl...
Ich weiss nicht, was das ist.
* Lachen *
Ich hatte immer einen 6er-Schnitt.
- Wieso hast du keinen mehr?
Ich checke die Themen nicht mehr,
weil ich keine Zeit habe
und gestresst bin.
Ich mache im Moment
schon weniger für die Schule,
aber es ist nicht knapp oder so.
Ich merke den Unterschied schon,
dass ich manchmal
wirklich gar keine Zeit habe,
aber ich könnte weniger machen
und dafür mehr für die Schule.
Das ist natürlich
auch meine Entscheidung.
Ich habe jetzt in Mathe ...
Meinem Gefühl nach wird's eine 2,
im Deutsch eine 3,5.
Jonas, Fanny und Elaine sind
in ihrer Freizeit wieder unterwegs,
diesmal
zu einem Medientraining in Bern.
Auch Kollegen aus der Westschweiz
sind dabei.
SP-Jungtalent und Klimaaktivist
Dimitri Rougy leitet das Training.
Der Aufmacher
heute im "SonntagsBlick" ist:
"Wie grün ist die Jugend wirklich?"
Und da ist natürlich
die Geschichte ganz klar,
die der "Blick" machen will.
Eigentlich geht es darum:
"Ja, ist ja schön und gut."
"Jetzt gehen sie alle demonstrieren,
aber was tun sie denn wirklich?"
Man individualisiert also ein Thema,
was eigentlich sehr spannend ist,
weil das den Ball natürlich
komplett zu uns zurückwirft
und es uns dann eigentlich
als "Grännichinder",
also ein wenig trotzig darstellt.
Wir sind plötzlich in der Funktion,
wo wir sagen müssen:
"Ja, wir essen auch alle vegan
und gehen auch nie mit dem Flugzeug
in die Ferien", etc.
Ich meine, diese Fragen
werden ja weiterhin kommen.
Sollen wir einfach sagen,
wir antworten nicht mehr,
oder wir wollen kein Interview
zu diesem Thema geben?
Wie ...
Inwiefern können wir das lenken?
Wir müssen nicht
zu allem eine Antwort geben
oder sie gleich ablehnen.
Wir können auch zurückfragen.
Ein Journalist
des Onlineportals "Nau"
trainiert mit ihnen
das Interview vor der Kamera.
Noch etwas rüber!
Soll ich in die Kamera schauen
oder zu dir?
Du schaust immer schön zu mir.
Die Kamera ist jetzt nicht da.
Jetzt haben eben Tausende in Zürich
und anderen Städten demonstriert.
Das ist vielleicht auch
ein Peak der ganzen Bewegung.
Es muss jetzt ja weitergehen. Man
kann nicht zig andere Demos machen.
Was kommt jetzt?
Was, finden Sie, wäre jetzt richtig?
Was als Nächstes sicher kommt,
ist der 15. März.
Das wird noch einmal
ein Grossevent sein,
weil wir dann wirklich
auch international ...
In 36 Ländern werden Menschen
fürs Klima auf die Strasse gehen.
Das wird sicher noch einmal riesig.
Wir können uns dort
noch einmal toppen, würde ich sagen.
Wenn wir z.B. auf die Wahlen
im Herbst Einfluss nehmen wollen ...
Was wollen wir dort eigentlich?
Eben: Lass dir Zeit!
Wenn ich die Frage gestellt habe,
kannst du auch vielleicht
1 Sek. warten und nachdenken ...
Mhm.
- ... und dann reden.
Wenn ich das Mikro hinhalte
nicht sofort:
"Jetzt muss ich anfangen und sofort
mit der besten Antwort kommen."
Okay.
Gibt es denn etwas,
was du mitnehmen wirst ...
Entschuldigung,
können wir das nochmals machen?
Ja, ist gut. Was sind die Sachen,
die du vom heutigen Tag mitnimmst?
Sagst du: "Wenn eine Kamera läuft,
mache ich das so."
Ich werde sicher mitnehmen, dass man
Journalisten auch sagen kann:
"Nein, so weit gehe ich
und so weit nicht."
"Das will ich, das will ich nicht."
"Und ich komme auch nur
zu gewissen Bedingungen."
Nele wartet
auf ihren Kollegen Kasimir.
Zusammen wollen sie an die nationale
Klimastreikkonferenz in Bern.
... äh, aber er ist jetzt weg?
Gut. Super. Danke sehr.
Vor drei Tagen
hat der Basler Grosse Rat
die Resolution der Bewegung
deutlich angenommen
und für Basel-Stadt
den Klimanotstand erklärt.
Nele ist glücklich.
Ein Megaerfolg, natürlich.
Wir sassen alle auf der Tribüne
und fieberten mit.
Obwohl man nicht klatschen darf,
mussten wir ein bisschen klatschen,
als sie sie annahmen.
Es ist ein Megaerfolgserlebnis.
Jetzt müssen wir schauen,
dass es nicht so läuft:
"Wir haben etwas erreicht,
jetzt ist fertig."
Das war jetzt mal der erste Schritt.
Die beiden sind Pfadileiter.
Sie wollten
ihre Gruppen nicht hängen lassen
und haben deshalb
den Anfang der Konferenz verpasst.
Das war ein verdammter Stress.
Ich habe mein Deutschbuch vergessen.
- Dein Deutschbuch?
Wir haben eine Prüfung in Literatur-
geschichte über etwa 100 Seiten.
Wir haben im Unterricht
nichts gemacht,
und ich habe natürlich
auch zu Hause nichts gemacht.
Seit drei Monaten
investieren diese Jungen
ihre Energie v.a. in Klimaanliegen.
Nele hätte schon ein paar Ideen,
was man aus dem Klimanotstand
nun machen könnte.
Unsere Vorschläge wären: sicher
mehr autofreie Plätze in Basel.
Wir arbeiten,
und das wäre sehr cool,
an kostenlosen
öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln.
Dann Flugsteuern.
Und ein grosser Punkt
ist sicher auch,
die Netto-CO2-Emissionen im Inland
auf null zu bringen.
Dass man so langsam
die richtigen Schritte unternimmt.
Wie immer läuft
die Kommunikation auf Hochtouren.
Ohne WhatsApp wäre die Klimabewegung
wohl kaum so in Schwung gekommen.
Alles läuft über WhatsApp.
Ich glaube, inzwischen
würde es gut ohne funktionieren,
aber das Problem war der Anfang.
Dass wirklich so schnell ...
Innerhalb von drei Tagen.
- Genau.
So schnell
eine so grosse Bewegung loszutreten,
das hätte ohne WhatsApp
nicht geklappt.
Ja, definitiv.
- Leider.
Oh, schau mal!
Sie haben was geschrieben.
Von der heutigen Konferenz werden sie
nicht mehr viel mitbekommen.
Aber am nächsten Morgen um 10 Uhr
stehen sie
gemeinsam mit 300 Jugendlichen
aus der ganzen Schweiz auf der Matte.
Nach modernsten
Lern- und Arbeitsmethoden
beginnen die Jungen den
vollgepackten Tag mit Entspannung.
And then you start to realise
that you're actually breathing.
I would propose some stretching.
For me it's a little difficult.
* Rumpeln, Lachen *
Was kann alles unter dem Namen
Klimastreik passieren?
In Gruppen diskutieren
die Schülerinnen und Schüler
die unterschiedlichsten Themen.
Bei uns ist es z.B. so:
Wir sind non-violent.
Wir bekennen uns politisch nicht.
Das sind Grundsätze,
denen jede Aktion entsprechen muss.
Wie machen wir das mit der Zeit?
Wir haben nur 30 Min.,
um ein Riesenthema zu behandeln.
Da alles Basisdemokratisch abläuft
und auf Konsens beruht,
ist jeder Prozess
natürlich megaanstrengend,
aber ich finde, es lohnt sich,
denn am Ende
hat man eine Entscheidung,
die wirklich für alle gut ist.
Das zeichnet sich aus.
Nina, Nico, Pauline,
Nele, Fanny, Andri, Elaine, Jonas -
alle sind hier, alle sind motiviert.
Die positive Gruppendynamik
beflügelt sie, weiterzumachen.
Wir haben erst angefangen,
einen Riesenwirbel zu machen.
Wir werden weiterhin
auf unseren Forderungen bestehen.
Die müssen erreicht werden,
sonst haben wir keine Zukunft.
Wir werden weitermachen,
bis wir das erreicht haben.
Aber ich denke,
dass Politiker/-innen gezeigt haben,
dass sie nicht fähig sind,
Verantwortung zu übernehmen.
Sie benehmen sich wie Kinder -
in der Schweiz und in ganz Europa.
(Alle) On est plus chaud, plus chaud,
plus chaud que le climat ...
* Musik übertönt den Sprechgesang. *